is coach coach taking a selfie there
he is i like it he's human maybe the
coach could dial up some
some deep patterns and maybe salvi can
go deep he may bring in mahomes and
relief tonight who knows
it's kyle zimmer making a rare start he
will be the royals
opener tonight finish him here and he
does
with the nasty slider at 84 miles an
hour
and up the middle for a base hit he
found a hole threw for a single
and a good start for alex tonight
swaying and a miss on another slider so
that's two strikeouts on the slider
see none of the red sox have ever faced
zimmer before so that's always good red
sox starter nick pivetta six
and two but he has been scuffling
double that's a fair ball
which stays hot
he had seven hits in 13 at bats in the
detroit series
and opens the boston series with a
double down the line
ball four and the royals have their
first two base runners on and the bottom
of the first
but now two down in the o2 pitch to
mondissey
hot shot arroyo handles it throws it and
gets him
boy that was cranked finish him on a
slider here
well he does at 82 miles an hour third
strikeout for kyle
reaches out flares that one into left
charging on dozier can't get it it dunks
down
for base hit so renfro is on second red
sox hit here
vasquez 257 he's homer three times
trying to go up the middle and it
squeaks through for a base hit
red throw to second and stopping there
this could be two touches second goes to
first they get the double play
nicely done had a lot of
really interesting matches ground ball
up the middle into center field that's a
good advantage
taylor and he's thinking about second
base but
it's a good thing he hit the brakes
flying in left center but room there for
santana on the run danny gets to it
side retired arroyo on deck
gonna line that one into right field put
a good swing on that one a little bobble
by merrifield but
he's gonna hold with a single
knock that one into the right center
field down for a base hit again not hit
terribly hard
but because of that santana goes first
to third and the red sox have them on
the corners with nobody out the red sox
have yet to hit a ball hard they've got
five hits on the night here is verdugo
in a big spot first and third nobody out
2-1 pitch that one hit pretty hard
that falls down for a base hit a run-in
santana will score arroyo moves on down
to third
and verdugo after a very nice start as
the red sox are taking a one-nothing
lead he's two for two yeah the hardest
hit ball tonight right there to verdugo
ball in his eyes
two-third gutierrez will go second one
now they're coming home
and they have got him at the plate royo
took off and then he stopped and then
nikki lopez with a head he plays saying
since he stopped
we can get him easy he likes to start
off a lot of opponents
with his breaking ball throw that slider
curve 53 percent of the time it goes
fastball here
and salvi makes him pay by banging it to
[Applause]
left
struck him out with it so two down
pivetta trying to wriggle off the hook
again we
will see if he does against modesty
trumani two fastballs
his first time up in a row and he didn't
swing at either one of them how about
that brings that
one high and deep down the right field
line
into the corner it goes and gone
home run alberto mondassie three to one
royals
there's a difference maker yep there's
some timing for you right there
[Applause]
went chasing it's exactly where we
wanted to throw it he struck him out
and that's just his second k in the book
tonight yeah we've been seeing a lot of
this
obviously all year for a long long time
that high fastball plays
it's way out of the zone looking for
another quick out
who gets it nasty breaking ball
back-to-back case for nick pavetta
you talk about a big league breaking
ball 12-6 look at that thing
that is a beautiful piece of work
three-two and a base hit knocked into
the left field by marwan gonzalez so red
sox have the leadoff man on in the fifth
holding and it is ball four
red sox take their first free pass
tonight
struck him out high heater
jd martinez he has struck out he's also
hit into
an odd double play his 1-2 pitch
a little ground ball up the middle it
gets through for a base head so that'll
bring in a run
gonzalez in the score to make it 3-2 an
rbi for jd his 42nd
curveball c9 ground ball didn't hit it
very hard who cares got it run
so bubitch is out santana is on the
royals still lead three to two
[Applause]
swung on and missed he struck him out
touches home plate
and a big strikeout by the veteran irvin
santana
the sox leave him loaded
breaking ball swatted at and missed and
look at him
kind of glare out at nick pavetta yeah
good curve ball all night long he's had
a lot of good
curveballs 2-2
another breaking ball cut onto miss to
put him away back-to-back case yeah how
about that curveball again
he's not gonna hang it first and second
runners will be on the move there they
go and he struck him out he missed it by
about six inches
side retired
lion that's pretty well hit to right
field that's going to be over the head
of the right fielder merrifield
vasquez on his way into second base and
he is there standing up
for the first red sox extra base hit of
the ball game
it comes with one down here in the sixth
yeah maryfield looked like he had a beat
on this ball
he kept looking at it and looking at it
and he probably said i'm not going to
get there
ground ball to first is a fair ball
carlos santana has it he'll go to the
bag and that's the inning and irvin
santana
works around the one out double one and
two on nikki lopez
fastball is lined into left field for a
base hit
he's had three really good swings
and he's on with two down in the sixth
inning here is whit who ripped a double
down the left field line his first time
up there he goes and the pitch to wit is
lined up the right field line
fair by a foot down into the corner
nikki scores and merrifield is into
second base with an rbi double
oh that's right move that runner wit
with his team leading 17th double
hit sharply santana nice play gives it
up to jake
two out looked like federer verdugo was
going to get in that ball
by him but you know what santana cat
quick over there is able to jump on it
and brent's
covering first with no problem good
athlete
stole a hit from him with some good
defense tonight
swing and a foul tip a fastball at 99
and jake brents comes in in the seventh
and gets the red sox three up three down
salvador perez to lead off inning number
seven rhino as rose try to add to a 4-2
lead
[Applause]
high in the air deep to right renfro
is back it's gone
number 18 for salvador perez
and the royals lead it five to two one
down for
rafi was a tough night
high deep drive to center taylor back in
the track the wall
leaps up can't get it it is gone
rafael devers is 17th so the red sox
edge a little bit closer in kansas city
as he hits one 4-24 to center field
in there strike three call arroyo
furious
jim wolfe with a late call and just
threw him out of the ball game
he came right down the middle dyson to
the corner
right you are hug attack him
get the out matheny's team snaps the
six-game
losing streak home runs by monday and
perez
and the royals win it five to three wow
this is the ball club right here that
royals fans believe in